we are drafting the most motivated
players for 2020 today chris i've got
the trivia question for you that will
determine the first pick who was the
last player to win the nfl's mvp award
after being cut
by an nfl team
wow the la
i'm going to have to that's got to be
peyton manning no
you are correct sir bye
got them bam
gosh it feels good to know all the
answers uh i don't know where there's
there's two really obvious picks here i
don't know
i mean i gotta go with cam newton i
almost feel like it's not even fair like
we shouldn't even let him be picked for
this draft because it's in honor of him
but yes so it should have been the cam
newton memorial drive right it should
have been the cam newton memorial draft
but it's too late now and i've already
picked cam newton so uh i mean cam
newton
what i mean the guy was the mvp of
football four years ago
didn't find a team
you know sitting there at home like damn
am i gonna be able to starting
quarterback am i gonna have to be a
backup behind some guy that i'm clearly
more talented than or have a better
career resume then so it's hard not to
think that cam newton isn't going to be
extremely motivated first off he was cut
by the team that drafted him number one
two he sat on the sidelines and wondered
what team was gonna freak him freaking
sign them all together and then you know
three it's of course the hate of oh is
it going to work in new england and all
those things so cam newton's about as
motivated as you're going to find
yeah and uh he's as motivated as the guy
who'll be my first pick who i think was
going to be your co-first pick who would
have been your first pick if it had been
the cam newton draft and he would have
been exempt right and that's the guy
that cam newton is replacing in new
england it's tom brady tom brady in his
mind disrespected by bill bella check
done with belichick never appreciated by
belichick ready to move on and prove
that he can win without bill that's the
subtext for
the nfl season this year and next year
and however many more both guys are
still in football what can belichick do
without brady what can brady do without
belichick and brady is highly motivated
to show that he can do as well if not
better away from belichick than
belichick can do without him of course
that's complicated by belichick getting
a highly motivated cam newton that
raises the stakes significantly but i
think that just makes brady even more
motivated well he's certainly motivated
there's no doubt yeah you're right and
he's going to want to show the whole
world that it wasn't new england and
it's you know wasn't belichick and that
he he certainly had a big stake in that
which we all know we do you know i mean
there is no doubt about that but i i
understand him being motivated by there
and i'm not so sure do we really think
uh you know i don't know who's more who
should be more motivated who should feel
more disrespected tom brady
or oh aaron rodgers
my freaking team traded up in the first
round to take a raw quarterback when i'm
in my prime still
what the hell i mean yes aaron rodgers
my second pick
how could he not be one of the most
motivated football players in the league
right now i mean he was in the mvp
conversation for a good part of the year
last year i mean he was doing special
things yeah leading a team the number
two number two you know uh ranking in
the nfc and then to sit there on draft
night and get no help and all those
things and to maybe realize that the
writing's on the wall that you're at a
short time in green bay yeah it's hard
for me not to look at aaron rodgers and
think he's not going to have a red hot
poker next his butt all year ready to go
yeah and it's it's
it's a weird mindset because he's going
to be extra motivated to do even better
while also thinking if you guys had just
drafted a receiver with the first round
pick or the fourth round pick you used
to move up in round one or both it would
be even easier for me to excel so here i
am busting my ass even harder by virtue
of the fact that you've made it harder
for me by beginning the process of
retooling the offense for the days when
i'm gone i just don't know how much that
motivation is going to translate into
anything because they haven't given him
the help that he needs to take it to the
next level i mean there's nowhere to go
but down for the packers this year 13
and three kind of an illusion last year
they kind of weren't that good they kind
of weren't a 13-3 team chris i think you
and i agree we saw the result when they
when they crossed paths with the 49ers
in the nfc championship game and had a
chance for that mulligan from the egg
they laid i remember going back to that
sunday night game
in santa clara
when the packers lost there and it was
you know a play here a play there
they're actually not as far away as we
yeah they are and uh they're getting
farther away so that's gonna be harder
for aaron rodgers all right next one for
me is ezekiel elliott you know we've
already seen and heard what he's had to
say about the criticism about the
respect that he doesn't get and you
think about last year he missed training
camp he was working out on his own while
he was holding out for a new deal and i
think with with all the talk about dak
prescott and his money and the new
coaching staff and cd lamb and all that
i think ezekiel elliott is tremendously
motivated to get back and have the kind
of season to put him in line for that
payday and maybe he realizes in
hindsight
he would have had a better 2019 if he
hadn't held out but he had to hold out
to get what he got and now he's got to
justify what he got or he's not going to
be getting it for much longer i think
we're going to see him come out just
like we did in his first couple years in
the nfl and really really provide punch
to that offense on the ground and open
up the passing game for the cowboys i
hope so you know and and you know we're
probably one of those or at least i am
one of those guys that you know maybe
doesn't respect ezekiel as much as i
should only because i expect a lot out
of them because i i see greatness in the
guy i do i've already seen it so that
was what was bothering to me last year
yeah i hold him to a very high high
you know
what do i want to say high bar yeah he's
the highest paid running back in
football he's got a good old line and i
think he's extremely talented and you
know what what i want to just like we
talked about last year we want to see
more of man you're in the open field
it's you and one guy you can't get go
down for the 18-yard gain there that's
got to be a 40-yard gain or a 50-yard
gain or whatever it may be and i think
you're right i think we're going to see
a guy that's pretty pissed off and feels
a little disrespected this year so i'm
with you man there's so many to pick
from mike i don't i'm going to stay at
running back i'm going to go with david
johnson houston texans i mean how can he
not be motivated i mean
all anybody's done is talk crap about
him for the last two years you know oh
it's not working in arizona last year
what the hell is going on there gets
traded for deandre hopkins i mean people
act like he was david johnson's a
garbage can they're oh they traded
deandre hopkins for a garbage can you
know i think he's a guy that's gonna be
motivated by everything that he's
hearing 10 million dollars a year for
that guy billy o'brien's crazy this is a
guy that's extremely talented how to
deal with some injuries and got involved
with the you know coaching change and
not fitting the scheme and you know
being banged up and all that so i gotta
think he's gonna be ready to go and
ready to show his a game this year
it really is amazing that the cardinals
got the value they did i mean this was
this was a ball and chain for them that
contract and they use the transition tag
on kenyon drake and they clearly wanted
to move on but it's a new chapter it's a
new offense it's a new opportunity for
david johnson and i agree with you he is
going to be motivated last year for me
is derek carr it's got to be derek carr
right we we spent a lot of time last
week talking about how he's tired of
being disrespected and chris one thing
you and i didn't discuss because i think
it happened after thursday lincoln
kennedy who does the raiders radio
broadcast came out and said hey if
you're feeling disrespected play better
yeah it's time to put up or shut up uh
um i suspect that derek carr is upset
about that somebody who's under the the
family umbrella calling out derek carr a
former raider a guy who lit the the fire
last year for their home opener for the
last time in oakland lincoln kennedy
saying those things it just shows that
there is an expectation for derek carr
that he hasn't lived up to he'd better
be motivated and be motivated play
better no more excuses no more whining
nothing other than going out and playing
well and uh we'll see if he's got the
motivation he's got the motivation we'll
see if he got the talent the ability the
decision making the maturity to make
that happen yeah all right we have the
the uh the picks for today chris has cam
newton aaron rodgers david johnson i've
got tom brady ezekiel elliott and
derrick carr there are plenty more guys
bond miller exactly you know there was a
lot of good jack prescott adrian adrian
peterson's always highly motivated now
that he's got an opportunity to be the
number one guy in washington it'll be
even more overmade up motivated philip
rivers that we can get on and on but we
just did those sick
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports